المختلفه وصارت جملته الشهيره كل رايح
بطله الكوميكس على السوشيال ميديا ضيف
اليوم الفنان محمد جمعه
[موسيقى]
مسلسل مسلسل الزياره هو مسلسل ناس كتير
حست انه قصصو موجوده في كل بيت مصري
وبتعبر عن كل بيت مصري احكي لنا الكواليس
زياره بقول انها من الناس وللناس
الحواديت اللي هي حكايات متقاطعه اسم
العمل بالكامل
هم حواديت من جوه بيوتنا
والمهم اللي فيها ان احنا بنقول مشكله
وبنقول الحل ده الاهم كله رايح اسلوب حياه
لما بفكر في كله رايح
بحسبها حزب عجيبه جدا كل الناس بتقول لك
المستقبل وانا عايز اعمل عشان المستقبل
وانا عايز اعمل عشان المستقبل وبجري وممكن
اظلم ناس وممكن اؤذي ناس وممكن اعمل حاجات
كتير عشان المستقبل
طب ممكن اسالك سؤال هو المستقبل ايه هو
الموت هو المستقبل ما هو احنا اخر
المستقبل ده هنموت
بتضحكي طب فكري فيها والله العظيم هل فعلا
رفضت اتجسد شخصيه عم ضياء مره تانيه في
فيلم انا رفضته كفيلم سينما انما كعمل عم
ضياء ابن السوشيال السوشيال ميديا اللي
صنعت فانا كنت عايز اشتغل على وفعلا احنا
كتبنا مسلسل
ما قبل عم ضيع يعني
ومسلسل كوميدي جدا
وكنت عايز اعمل المسلسل ده للديجيتال فقط
لان هو ابن سوشيال ميديا فلازم يروح في
السوشيال ميديا بس لحد دلوقتي ما فيش جهه
انتاجيه يعني تبنت المشروع لو حصل هنعمل
شاركت في مسلسل في بيتنا روبوت بسبب ابنك
اه ده حقيقه
ابني بيتفرج على في بيتنا روبوت وبيحبه
جدا وبيحب لذيذ وزومبا وبيحب كل
الكركترات دي فلما كلموني قلت لهم انا
موافق انه هم كانوا عايزين نضيف شرف فقلت
لهم انا موافق فهم انبسطوا جدا قلت لهم لا
مش عشانكم يعني علشان ابني بيتفرج على
المسلسل فدي انا عايز اروح لابني
في الحاجه اللي هو بيحبك بالست ليه دايما
فيها جدل كده راجل ست كله هياخد على قفاه
في راجل يستاهل الاحترام وفي راجل ما
يستاهلش وفيه ست الاحترام وفي ست ما
تستاهل